US intelligence agencies believe Russia
used disinformation warfare to try to
interfere with the 2016 presidential
election an American intelligence report
finds that one of the weapons in the
Kremlin's Arsenal was its state-run news
network
RT formerly russia today which can be
seen in this country sunday on 60
minutes Lesley Stahl talks with artis
editor-in-chief margarita Simeon about
those allegations let's talk about
Russian interference in our election
mm-hmm which our intelligence agencies
tell us happened you believe them just
like you believe I believe weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq didn't you
believe that continue to believe that
Russian interference in American
elections happened in five years you
will know that it didn't it's also
Facebook and Twitter say the same thing
now oh what do they say days today say
they say that the Russians used their
websites to perpetrate pro-trump anti
Hillary Clinton information I can't deny
that there could be in Russian media
that had their opinion on Twitter on
Facebook whatever broadcast is that bad
is that illegal isn't that what the
American media do as well British media
supported Hillary no problem with that
no interference nothing French media
supported Hillary no problem with that
some Russian media supported Trump oh my
god I don t support Trump no Archie did
not support Trump was attempting our
fault is that Archie did not support
Hillary either I know that yeah I wanted
to win somebody who would be nicer to
Russia did you get that
no is it even possible we don't know one
curiosity is Artie's connection to
Michael Flynn president Trump's former
national security adviser who has pled
guilty to lying to the FBI in the Russia
probe Simon yawn invited him to Artie's
10th anniversary gala in 2015 you paid
him $45,000 to come to the event and sat
him next to mr. Putin it just conjures
up the idea
well if lencha lee he may have been some
kind of a conduit when he did get close
to Trump because he sat next to Putin in
not areas he sat next to Putin but there
was some relationship with Putin who
didn't know who he was
I give you my word on that well it looks
like a fascinating - yeah I talked to
Leslie about this and she said it was
really interesting to spend time with
someone UN that she was very impressive
and it's kind of at the heart of many of
these allegations that have been put
forward about collusion and it's a part
of this we haven't heard about I mean
you want to hear more from her and what
what what her explanation is and if you
want to hear more guess what replace
this Sunday on 60 minutes learn when
Simon Yan says she and other Russians
stopped being fans of the United States
that Sunday here on CBS